from one type of animal therapy to
another this stressful time has taken a
toll on everyone especially
young people living in underserved
neighborhoods nancy chen takes us to a
very unique place where horses are
giving these children hope and
helping them heal the kids at this
equine therapy center in hartford
connecticut
patricia kelley's position is undeniable
i'm the alpha mayor
the one-of-a-kind non-profit ebony horse
woman is guided by black and hispanic
therapists and instructors
offering black and hispanic children
from struggling neighborhoods
a lifeline before they arrive here in
the morning what are they seeing
in their streets the night before
everything
they hear gunshots overnight nine ten
about 30 kids from the age of five come
together year round at no cost
what were you like as a seven-year-old
when you first got here oh god i was
mean
i didn't really like people
fourteen-year-old j.j edwards in his
unit patrol the streets around the
center
the same neighborhoods in which they
live i know a lot of kids is not going
to want to sit there and
talk to a therapist and talk about how
they feel like you could tell a
horse anything you're not going to say
nothing you're just going to sit there
and listen
the healing nature of these horses has
changed thousands of lives
since patricia kelly started 37 years
ago
anything that i can do
to help them i'm going to do
good girl entie chen cbs news hartford
connecticut